two things you can say to get around i  left my wallet at home the first thing  you do is you don't actually ask for  someone's payment first instead what you  do is you ask them for their id so they  take their wallet out and then they'll  hand you their id you'll write down  their information say cool let me swap  you for whatever card you want to use  now at that point they can't say they  left their wallet at home but let's say  that for some reason they say like i  left the car that i that i wanted to use  or whatever no problem do you have a  phone on you cool why don't you pull up  your banking app go to your statements  and then we can see your account number  on the top right and we can write that  down we can do an eca transaction just  like that